any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
today we're talking
to a preeminent cosmologist
a thinker
motivator and inspiration
and uh also my best man at my wedding
but
today we're going to talk about him and
that's professor stefan alexander my
oldest uh friend pretty much
and uh really as i say it inspiration
how are you doing today my brother steph
hey um
this was one of um
the many interviews that i'm looking
forward to
i hope not that many but uh one of
the few few of many let's say you're
gonna say like top 20 interviews of of
the week of the day well you deserve all
the rich success that you are
engendering and that is of course stefan
alexander author of previously the jazz
of physics and now
fear of a black universe
and that uh title we're going to get
into in the cover of the book cover the
books not as interesting as jazz of
physics at least visually but the
content material is uh is just off the
charts i i can't i can't you know really
give you
uh
the claim that you deserve stuff on
because it's such a great book it's so
well written and it's uh and it is
really gonna open up new horizons uh but
before we do that before we get into the
meat and the guts of it the title is
inescapable as soon as i heard i was
like damn why didn't i write that as my
book
but you know i love chuck d and i love
public enemy flava flav
i've loved them for decades you know
that um but i could never get the
encomium i could never get the blurb
that you got i'm gonna read it here
none other than professor chuck d
rapper and co-founder of public enemy
who says about this book the rabbit hole
gets wrestled here an old school saying
applies the more you know the more you
don't know
that's really old so that's like
aristotle man
dance along this read into the unknown
and find out that this book may be the
best ever answer to
what is soul
and i'm just wondering man um do you
want me to read what chuck d said uh
what flavor flav said rather
yeah he said yo boy what time is it it's
time to read fear of a black universe
and he's got the huge cup now he didn't
say that um brother stefan tell me what
does this mean what is fear of a black
universe where'd you get the name
where'd you get the subtitle an
outsider's guide to the future of
physics
yes yes
well there's a funny story about that
and like if you
if you allow me so
um you've written a book um you're
losing the nobel prize and you know that
finding a good title is like tough
business right because you know you want
you want to draw the reader in
the books you know they're in the books
they see the book
and the title can draw them in so anyway
make a long story short
my editor tj kelleher kept
bothering me
what's what's the title of the book i
mean this is in the middle of writing my
book i don't have a title yet and i was
at some point i kept coming up with
titles and the titles were corny
and they were you know
like i'm not even going to waste time
telling you how corny some of these
titles were
um and he kept coming back and the you
know the marketing team kept come back
and saying nah that doesn't really cut
it not that whatever
so
one day i actually
um i invited tj to come to brown to give
some talks to different um you know
colleagues about writing you know
potentially
book deals and things like that um but
it was a an opportunity for me and him
to really hang out and talk more about
the book
and one i took him to this irish pub in
providence and it was like two this is
like pre-covert this is like a couple of
years ago
and i took him to this pub at late at
night and you know we're having a few a
few brews you know
and at some point
um
i decided and you know you've known me
for a long time you know i suck at being
sarcastic it's just not me to do that
right
i was like i'm going to be sarcastic
here and
i said i said tj i got the title of the
book for you
and it was a it was this is it
it was designed to just be a spoof right
it was a joke i said fear of a black
universe man
and and i left that behind and then a
month later you know
he i get i get a um a text from him he
goes that's it i met with the marketing
team they love it
and i was like really so anyway that's
kind of
but the truth of the matter is actually
um after some reflection i realized it
actually it was one of these um
intuitive types of things right that
deep down
the book is about um the title was oh
it's a it's a combination of things
right
in one sense
there's ambiguity to
in one sense it's like well
when we think about black and the idea
of the category of black blackness
and um you know that which you know that
that which is misunderstood right
ignored sometimes invisible
um
and stigmatized i mean so we you know
when we think about even our laws like
you know black body radiation was
misunderstood for why
black holes the singularity right the
event horizon what's inside dark matter
dark energy so we tend to in physics
just you know not you know give names
like that to doc this black this but
things we don't understand that are
mysterious
um it's a placeholder for those things
sometimes
also i just think also when we think
about like um society and sociology and
psychology you know the dark we're
afraid of the dark right um you know we
think about blackness like you know the
american notion of of being black when i
lived in europe i realized that you know
um white people out there even created
their own categories of like you know
well
you know they're stigmatized you know
being stigmatized right and um
and having also black ideas ideas that
can actually get you in trouble right
and so you might want to um
have a as a physicist maybe an idea that
is so out there and crazy
it may you know your colleagues may
write you off and kick you out of the
club they won't invite you to reindeer
games and these kind of things right you
won't get invited to a conference so
there's a fear in it so i think like in
that sense but primarily it really was a
nod to public enemy because i grew up
with um you know you know i was i grew
up in a bronx right not too far from
where you grew up
and um
and in the 80s and public enemy i still
wear you know i mean african medallions
and things like that all throughout
college right
um
you know one of my favorite lines i
think was from welcome to the terra dome
on the album fear of a black planet was
i got so much trouble on my mind refused
to lose
it was you know you're like you know
yeah i got trouble in my mind man like
but i refuse to lose you know so it was
a nod to
um to that time of my life and and also
an acknowledgement that you know despite
the fact that
some people will say i have the subtitle
the outsiders guy people say you're not
an outsider you're a full professor at
an ivy league school but there was a
part of me that was like no i still
choose in a sense
to to to have to you know to um
acknowledge
the outsider in me
um and and celebrate it and and see it
actually as a positive so the book was
also a celebration not a complainant
okay and not a what was me i'm an
outsider but actually
here are the hidden advantages actually
to being an outsider so the book kind of
goes into that as well that's my
long-winded kind of answer yeah that's
your long-winded short story
but you know my grandfather
invented cliff notes right
and i asked him how did he do it and he
said well
he said let me make a long story short
no i'm just kidding uh that's an old
joke um
one of the other uh cover uh encomium
blurbs that appear on on fear of a black
universe uh comes from our mutual friend
the now president of the simons
foundation professor david spurgle
passed uh three time guest
on into the impossible you're a
four-time guest on into the impossible
so you still beat uh brother david
but he said this book is effectively a
sequel to a brief history of time now i
remember meeting professor stephen
hawking in london in 95 96 when we were
both hot shot young grad students at
brown you were hotter than i was but uh
but anyway
and i and there was a question posted
okay you actually by the way i got to
give you a shout out uh without you i
wouldn't be drinking the beverage that's
in here right now which is coffee you
introduced me to coffee at age 21 22
whenever we met and we used to go to
ocean's coffee roaster shout out uh to
no longer pour some coffee out on the
sidewalk right but uh brother david
spurgle says uh this book compares to a
brief history of time now when i heard
stephen
hawking asked why did you write a brief
history of time he said because i needed
to pay for my daughter's college tuition
and i always thought that was kind of
silly now i know you've got a lovely
daughter but that wasn't the reason you
wrote this book
but how does it compare to brief history
of time why is it as as i believe the
case to be true uh a worthy successor to
that most famous of all popular science
books
yeah
um it's really funny and
it was probably the biggest compliment
um that i think any science writer
physics writer could ever get
and i don't know if um i'm allowed to
say this but let's say david spurgle
um
you know is
one of the most important cosmologists
on the planet today
um
and
so coming from it was a big deal but
also you know he was
i think it's public knowledge maybe but
he was offered the location chair he was
offered hawking's position so who better
to know for
to come from than him than david spurgle
um again
again that was that's a conjecture i'm
not certain that that was the case but
um in fact check that but either way my
point here
maybe he was being considered for the
location chair that might be the more
correct way of saying it um but either
way
i um the first science book i ever laid
my hands on and it was given to me i was
you know at diwa clinton high school in
the bronx new york 6 000 students
we had you know it was roughly 60
dropout rate but this woman a father
went to my um high school his name was
barney sharon s-h-a-r-i-n
and susan sharon wanted to um
kind of reach out to to just you know
count promising students
and give a scholarship an academic
scholarship in her father's name barney
sharon
um
i think you know stanley also went to my
high school penalties for my high school
right you know make a long story short
you know um
and
but anyway um
and she gave me this book as a gift when
i was 15 years old a brief history of
time
um and it's funny because i actually
have my copy of abbreviation time still
here with me um
and of course i just wanted it
i was actually talking about the other
day so it was right it's here but anyway
um
and
it's one of these things where when
you're when you're writing you know you
don't realize the the impact
um but books really important books are
going to have in your writing
so i actually deliberately when i was
writing this book wanted to write a book
in the with a similar type of format as
a brief history of time and another book
which is a character of physical law
um and so let me give you an example
what i mean by that that's my fine man
that's his time
so in feynman's book he wanted to kind
of spell out thinking about physics in
terms of principles that maybe we can
just think about maybe the simplest
principles and explain
much of physics with these principles
and i wanted to play a similar game here
but i wanted to use these principles i
wanted to do that to liberate the reader
from um
from jargon and like you know the mess
of complicated equations and things like
that i wanted to say okay if we can tie
down these three principles and i and
and really explicate them at the
beginning of the book then i can
use that as a basis or as the ingredient
and the basic ingredients to them talk
about for me the most pressing and the
pressing
um
questions on the horizons of the field
the field of fundamental physics
cosmology particle physics and quantum
gravity
um and unification so i wanted to kind
of
riff on that in the same manner that
stephen hawking did
and remember one of the things that
really fascinated me and really caught
me hooked me on hawking was you know he
asked one of you he did go there he he
said you know i want to know you know
did god have a choice in creating
universe right and like so he also
discussed
matters that maybe we were taught not to
discuss in our education as physicists
and so likewise i did similar things i
talked about i i you know i gave myself
the liberty to talk about questions
about life and consciousness
um and like you know
um
some aspects of spirituality
but not very too far away from the basic
principles
that
the book you know establishes at the
very beginning
so it's in that sense so i was surprised
not surprised i didn't tell david when i
gave him the book to read well when the
book company gave a book to read that
the book was inspired by hawkin he read
it and inferred that on his own so that
so that me was very pleasing
yeah i have to be honest with you there
are a lot of books that have come out
lately from colleagues of ours you know
that talk about experiences of of
african americans and and other people
of color in science et cetera um and you
know from the from the title and maybe
even from the outsiders i thought that's
what it was going to be about i mean as
they say don't judge a book by its cover
but on the other hand what else do you
have to judge a book by you know it's
like we have to be bayesians and look at
uh analysis with the data that we have
and so even though knowing you i was i
thought it was incongruous you know
because i didn't think you were gonna
take that that attack where you would
say you know this is the experience of a
black you know man in america in the
bronx you know coming from trinidad
immigrant story all the stuff that
you've been through and it really wasn't
about that i mean jazz of physics was
more kind of autobiographical this is
kind of um i call this you know kind of
more like a um
uh a flight plan you know as a pilot you
know i'm a pilot right yes yeah no
that's a good analogy actually you
remember when we flew together stuff
well i have very good memories of that
when we got serious weather and i was
like okay this guy is going to navigate
okay this guy who you know i i i
first
this is the way i'm going to choose to
die that's exactly right this guy who
can't you know clean up
a plate after he cooks it at the house
is going to take me on a flight across
the the uh rhode island sound there no
it didn't it worked out okay we're both
we're both here to talk about uh but
you know i see it as a flight plan where
can physics go where can things like
consciousness go where can things like
aliens and dark energy and the greatest
mysteries so i want to say you know
normally you hear questions like this to
an eminent scientist like yourself
normally ask me what got you interested
in science what what you know what
inspires you i don't want to know that i
don't want to know that i already know
that by the way
but i want to ask you as a scientist now
not as a kid
what is your curiosity burning brightest
about
yeah that's a good one um you know i've
always had you knew that when i was a
grad student
we were grad students in the same year
that
um
like i was always when penrose had this
theory with stuart hameroff remember
about you know uh his theory about the
mita you know mitochondrion being the
harnessing quantum information to to
speak about consciousness in the brain i
went to humphrey marist who's an eminent
you know eminent um
um experimental physicist and i said and
i went to i made a case to humphrey that
we should do an experiment like a laser
experiment with um you know
by studying basically the
waveguide properties of mitochondria
like to see whether or not you know you
can have quantum coherence so i was
already like you know i already have
this kind of fascination with the
connection between
physics and biology and life but at a
more deeper level not at the level of
like you know atomic bonds and like
chemistry which already is a connection
between quantum mechanics already um and
life because you need
quantum chemistry is about right
bonding structures right and valence
shells and all that good stuff that's
quantum mechanics and you need that to
talk about proteins but you know the
more weird things about quantum quantum
tunneling you know these other weirder
things quantum entanglement right these
other um categories of quantum mechanics
that's even more bizarre and whether or
not these things have something to say
about life i already was exploring that
but of course
you know the importance of writing
papers and following the herd and
getting a good postdoc
um
and that bug never left me um and i
think this book was my way of um
exploring that you know we write books
sometimes to kind of explore
and um
better articulate um things that we have
in in our head and it's an opportunity
it's one format that we can you know
explore these questions and so the book
was so that let me say let me stop
talking my fascination these days is
okay given um you know what we know
about cosmology we know about dark
energy and dark matter and cosmic
inflation maybe the theory of the early
universe where space time might emerge a
space time an emergent property is it
something else and
whether or not like you know where do
where do we see
hints of of life and consciousness
um interpolating um those mysteries
right and the book does explore um some
of those questions and speculates on
that the same way in the same spirit of
like say
how feynman ends his book um
um in the character of physical law or
falcons in brief history of time
um as two good examples by the way very
tough acts to follow and i
you know the jury is out i don't think i
i owned up to it but it was an attempt
and so we see where it goes
but only by saying some crazy stuff
and yeah
which was my fear my fear of coming out
and just saying and saying that and i
think that you know
going back to the idea of like i think
one one the idea of like okay i'm a
black man or a black person doing
physics right i just double
what better way
right what better way
to um
to in to
to express that
then to
them to really go there in terms of um
in terms of theorizing right
like
so i don't know my my point was to sort
of like yeah
let's let me tackle some really really
hard questions in this book
let me speculate and let me not be
afraid of being wrong or even chastised
because of it because guess what that's
sometimes what it means to be um
to live in a world where you're already
stigmatized and so what fear do i have
it's already it already happens to me
you know so that's terrific and i wonder
you know if you could comment on because
you must have this happen a lot too
where
you know i note on my videos whenever i
post a video that's about cosmology or
about string theory and things like that
i get comments such as you know the
following that uh big bangs in an
oscillator flow or spiral cosmological
model my friend uh roger perlman et
cetera et cetera you know so i get all
these comments and you know they're
completely
unorthodox you know space is finite the
big bang never happened
time is infinite
um everything emerges from you know a
quadripolar pair i get a lot of you know
refreshingly candid uh new theories
shall we said i never see by the way i
never see experimentalists you know i
never see like oh here's an experiment
you know except nowadays i start to get
uh people wanting to investigate ufos
and things like that and so they are
proposing observations and i'm involved
with some of these things but anyway um
the point is
i got a couple i've got a lot of um
aliens so i can point them out to you
uh yeah so how do you draw the line like
because you and there's only so much
time in the day you need to apply a
low-pass filter
and uh and block off your time how do
you know like when someone's an outsider
like a nikola tesla or somebody like
that you know destined to change the
world or an elon musk or or
or even an einstein you know before he
was einstein he wasn't einstein as our
mutual friend jim gates always says how
do you know someone's an outsider versus
uh being totally out to lunch
that's a good that's a good um
let me see if i can address that with
the following notion um
and one of my heroes and you know part
my biggest hero in physics in terms of
personally is leon cooper
um nobel prize winner for super
connectivity and of course and i i
discussed there's a chapter where i talk
about his
his description of his discovery to me
when i was a when i was a graduate
student so when i was a postdoc i came
back to visit him
and i think this captures it but one of
the things that you know it occurred to
me with leon in the many years that i
i've known him almost 30 years as long
as i've known you
since we both knew leon when we were
first here
that's right um
we in fact both took advanced quantum
mechanics with me remember that class oh
i remember it yeah he told me i didn't i
didn't learn my undergraduate quantum
mechanics well enough to ask him about
uh
negative energy states and the direct
equation anyway he
he did so very gentlemanly and i teased
him i said well i learned quantum
mechanics from your textbook professor
cooper no i didn't
well
you know the thing about leon that's
weird that was crazy was that i was in
that class i used to sit in the back of
the room and one time i i said that what
i thought would be the most idiotic
thing and he was like well that's a
really good question and so he so he was
kind of one of these
um
right yeah
right so he'd get you so anyway but one
thing i i learned about leon right
was
like leon is so he knows so much right
but the thing that was interesting about
leon was that leon was not interested in
talking to other people that knew what
he knew
right because he was so smart he just
knew
so much science forget about this
physics
and so his interest was also talking to
people that knew things he didn't know
and so this balance i think you need
both i think it's not
you've got to be grounded i think one of
the things i tried to do in the book was
to ground the book like it really i have
um i you know i thought i did a really
good job in really describing quantum
field theory yeah in terms of mode
oscillators and as a combination of
special relativity
and um and the illustrations are killer
i mean i'll show you here
yeah yeah thank you i mean the field
ones i got my one of my daughters was
she went crazy with the highlighter and
one of these oh my god can you send me a
picture of that yeah well that's the
review on amazon leave it on amazon
wow wow
that's like i
i met her when she was a little baby so
that's amazing i got to get i got to get
a picture of that anyway yeah yeah the
the analogies the visual analogies are
so on point that it really
you know it does you never dumb things
down i mean you go into some serious
stuff with string gas cosmology we're
gonna get into that later that's one of
my favorite chapters but um you never
dumb it down and i think that's a sign
of respect for your audience and the
courage is you have to do that i think
yeah comes from this upbringing plus you
have a natural gift i would say i think
you wouldn't dispute that right
yeah um
yeah
i mean
i don't
it's hard for me to accept um what you
call confidence but i'll i thank you i'm
learning to accept compliments from time
to time because
um
but you know it's interesting let me say
another thing it just occurred to me
i grew up growing up in the bronx um i
think
you know one of the things that it just
let me say it another way
i grew up in an era
um
this is the first time i'm saying this
publicly actually
i i don't know if you knew this but i
was part um when i was 17 years old i
was approached by some friends of mine
to join a hip-hop group called timbuk3
and that was part of native tongue
and that group that group we used to go
to strong city studios up on alton
avenue that was run by africa bambada
jazz ej and rock buccano
and um i said you know being that studio
with jazzy jiren and my friends um who
were part of this group i was not a
rapper i was i was a beat maker i used
to sample my saxophone but i was very
much in
and here's the thing that's really
interesting
like
the when we were sampling and we were
taking like when we had taken elements
to make beats and make music we would
just draw from anything
so
the most obscure records you know like
walt disney records and
like all kinds of obscure things we
would basically take these elements and
bring them together and the art was
actually making it sound good
making it you know making it funky and i
think that
i was you know so i when i look at some
of the papers that i i wrote when i was
a postdoc and i was maybe
uh made fun of for
you know the string theorists would say
don't the loop quantum gravity people
are loopy don't even pay attention to
their theory and vice versa with other
things and when i look at some of my
papers it didn't matter to me like what
if i found useful just like a mixologist
or you know um doing a remix or you know
um
as a as a as a beat maker a hip-hop beat
maker you know the point was like you
wanted
whatever work whatever tools
um would work to to to um to make
something coherent
and do something that's scientifically
sound even if it meant making it of
course making a prediction or connecting
to experiment
um i i i didn't i didn't limit myself i
don't know there's another word i didn't
self-edit in that way right um so i
think that
going back to your question about
you know where do you see the where's
the divide in line and i think you need
you know
i look at it more like you you need to
be grounded and know and have your skill
set and and it's a it's a lifelong
process as a scientist okay just like as
a saxophonist it's learning to play the
sax is a lifelong thing um i can always
get better at that but i'm not going to
wait until i become john coltrane to try
some to do something creative
and so the to answer that question i
think it's important to put ideas out
there populate the landscape of ideas
right um i think this is also inspired
by our friend um eric weinstein and then
and then you know let people then shoot
it down let experiment shoot it down
let's not self-edit these ideas and
let's keep an open mind and then use our
methods and our techniques and you know
mathematics and experiments to then say
okay this is right this is wrong no one
has ever died from theorizing
maybe they have like you know didn't get
a grand proposal like funded but
you end the book on that note you know
nobody died from theorizing and that
must be from alba ashtakar you know
wonderful uh
your former former fellow colleague at
penn state uh but but the you know the
concept of of theorizing in public has
changed since the time of you know the
masters that we look up to even hawking
even
even feynman etc and i like to use a
thought example
uh imagine you go back to 1864.
uh in the uk in scotland there's a guy
by the name of james clerk maxwell and
he's got all these ideas he's got ideas
about the electromagnetic field and
equations that will bear his name and
later make be made into a version that
frank wilcheck our mutual friend calls
uh you know the maxwell equation on
steroids in the yang mills version that
you talk about in this book
and uh but he's working on it he's like
oh yeah well how do they how do these
field theories work how do these how do
these waves oscillate what are they
oscillated oh well there are these gears
and whirlpools in space and there are
these vortices he would have been
laughed out of his mind right people
would have tormented him they would have
like said he's ridic and guess what they
would have thrown the baby out with the
bathwater and we wouldn't know about
maxwell to this day so is there a
hindrance now with like theorizing in
public as eric has done you know and as
you know as other people my carlo
ravelli who's been a guest on the show
many times even lee smalling your
colleague and friend
endorser of the book
the situation has changed our mutual
friend um paul steinhardt
never he refuses to go on twitter he
refuses to go on social media and he's
got his own you know kind of bold
outsider like prediction so i guess the
thing i came away with yeah you can be
an outsider even if you're an insider
because there are enough people out
there that are trying to gun for it you
know take you down do whatever um but
you know speak about that the the
courage of a theorist because i think
you know in a certain sense
theorists are more courageous
because they can put their ideas out but
experimentalists are more bold because
they actually have to test it and you
know there's an old saying a theorist
only has to be right once in his or her
life but an experimental loss has to
only be wrong once in his life or her
life of course i proved that wrong right
i was wrong and i still live to tell a
tale but anyway what do you make of this
the is it does it take courage to do
what you do or is it like i'll throw it
out there it'll probably never get
tested so what difference does it make
yeah i think that if you want to play
safe as a theorist
um you know
um
you know you
i i don't want to use the word the best
description i have is follow the herd
there's a shepherd and there's a herd
and if like you know there's certain um
influential people or by the way
nowhere am i saying that there's
anything wrong with this i'm saying that
one game you can play is to just follow
the herd and follow what's fashionable
and what other people are writing about
and guess what i did that too right you
know when who's the herd who is the who
is the the chef who is the herd in this
i remember it was you know it's still i
mean when i was a postdoc string theory
was very fashionable people were writing
papers on brain brain worlds and
uh you know high dimensional
realizations of cosmology and i
um i wrote papers on that too yeah it
was fascinating papers those papers got
integrated
you know yeah i got i mean hundreds of
citations from um
two such papers that i wrote and
i learned a lot by the way i learned a
lot learned you know how to calculate in
higher dimensions and that sort of i
picked up skills and skill sets and
intuitions and all that kind of stuff it
was all worth it
um
one of my great mentors delayed joe
polczynski said you know string theory
is going to be useful for something and
i agree with that i mean it's technology
and it might it might still end up being
correct at the end of the day okay so
the jury is still out actually i wrote
these papers and it got me it got me a
great post i got me two great postdocs
because i was writing papers on that and
not in luke quantum gravity where there
were a few jobs and um available at the
time right so
so again that's one that's one one model
right um and of course i'm obviously
simplifying this so i'm
open to scrutiny right when i'm saying
this i'm definitely deliberately
simplifying things here um but then you
know if you're really going to aim for
something maybe big or bold
i think um
i guess the thing here is that if you
have an intuition or a hunch
and it stands outside of what's
fashionable
i say you know
the whole point is let me yeah i think
one way of
of doing this is say that when i was my
under my second post
my post soccer advisor michael peskin
used to just say just
basically shut up and calculate not not
directly but like
go away
just calculate this thing and come back
to me in a few weeks okay
and i remember at some point i was very
frustrated i was like man what's why is
this guy put me through this like you
know
uh go do these these loop diagrams and
come back you know where's the guy put
me through this and one day he said
something to me that blew me away
he goes he just out of the blue he goes
he goes you're doing this so that
so that you so that you can master the
stuff and then do what you use this to
do what you want to do with it
right so it's just like it sounds to me
like you know like learn how to play the
saxophone really well learn the
techniques go through all the epitomes
and the scales and the theory and all
this stuff right get it under your
finger not so that you can play the the
you know memorize the solo of john
coltrane giant steps but so you can make
your own stuff
and so
it isn't just to say like i'm gonna go
and like you know have some deliberately
have some audacious crazy idea that's
woo
but it's more like you do the hard work
you do this stuff you engage in
conversation you have sound boards
right and if you get lucky to have an
intuition that is
on the outside or is
that that you know
you're like oh my goodness like if i say
this my colleague's gonna laugh at me
what i'm saying is
go for it
and and and then use the techniques and
and and uh and the um
the math and all the stuff the tools
that you've developed
to help you know refine it into
something
that um that is communicable and might
even connect hopefully with experiment
so that's kind of where i was trying to
go with um
with it it's a dance and um i don't i
don't claim that i've that i that i know
the complete answer but the book and
write in the book i was exploring that
let me also say one last thing about
this too i mean i think one of the best
examples was michael faraday right
because faraday you know first of all
was an experimentalist i guess he was
not supposed to be theorizing but he had
his own theory about invisible lines of
force
well how woo and witchcraft do you want
to get there right
um during that time the 1800s i mean
like
if there was a steak to be burnt up to
say there's an invisible lines of force
and he was a laughingstock i mean his
idea was called idiotic and
the fundamental paradigm of our physics
is quantum field theory our fields
everything is made up of fields
so that's i think one of the great
ironies of i think what i'm talking
about but it's really hard to say how do
you actually do it yeah i mean and what
i do in the book is tell stories i try
to communicate
that instead of explain it away but like
by telling stories um so the book will
have you'll see a lot of stories of
different surprising things
schrodinger's reading of the vedic
philosophy and niels bohr and you know
paulie doing dream analysis with carl
young you know mr mr um
ultimate insight is saying your theory
is not even wrong right it's like
engaging in dream analysis you know
yeah
yeah and those guys were uh were buddies
right so uh
paulie and and uh and um and his friend
carl young yeah i had paul stein halpern
on last year to talk about their
unlikely relationship synchronicity yeah
i remember you talking about all that
stuff
the first year you know and there's
always a danger because like you're
telling me they're woowoo stuff and i'm
kind of like in my mind shooting the
message i'm like why is this guy into
like the orgone and the and the like
vedic stuff and then like all of a
sudden it comes well not the organ but
anyway everything comes from circles
remember i had that thick book on the
desk
oh my god that's nice
i just came in there i was like are you
reading like gretchen and rizzick you
know like no no it's like the very
contrary what i don't know um i never i
never got too deeply involved with that
but but i always thought you know this
is kind of out there but you need that
because it is the outsiders and it's not
just like diversity for let's say it
real i mean it's not like diversity as
your your friend of mine jim gates
always talks about it's like if you're
not diverse it hurts you the the the
non-diverse one you know who's just like
keeping things in check like it's gonna
hurt physics if we don't have a certain
perspective
um that's different from our traditions
because you know yeah we're all all kind
of living off the fumes of isaac newton
and and albert einstein etc um and and
some argue like sabine haasenfeld or
mutual friend um you know that physics
fundamental physics is kind of stagnant
in some sense although many people find
that controversial
but you know in this book you get into
something that actually sabina is now
working on which is like super fluid
dark matter
and that to me is like the ultimate like
totally out of left field
that combines your early work with with
leon cooper and his obvious titanic
contributions with a new method of
applying condensed matter physics to
cosmology so that's kind of
that only could come from an outsider
talk about that theory your theory and
the work that you and your colleagues
are working on about super fluid dark
matter
yeah and in fact that was a good example
that actually started with leon one time
i was in his office i went to visit him
at the time i was at penn state and um
so i you know i was
i was driving up to boston for some
reason maybe give a talk and i popped
into providence and to see him
and then he sits to me i'm wearing this
you know i remember his huge office in
his office and then
and then
he tells me
so i i tell him what i was working on
thinking that i was telling him
something clever and he goes you know
what you need to find a real problem and
do some real physics okay and he goes
you know a lot of people you go there's
a lot of people in your field
um
you know they stop working on the hard
problem because they and they they say
that like physics is stagnant and all
this stuff you know what they're just
scared you know they're scared to solve
a problem you know people thought
superconductivity was impossible to
solve it was solvable we solved it okay
so you know what find a real problem and
and go solve it and i was like
you mean like the really hard one like
you know these problems like the
singular all this thing he goes yeah
find a real he goes and he goes to the
blackboard and he goes i'll give you an
example
he goes you know people say that the the
big banks the singularities are you know
uh it's impossible to get around but let
me show you something and then he he
literally does a geometric series like a
re-summation
and shows that what you thought was a
singularity and a function right could
be re-summed and it's not singularity
and i was like wait a minute
that's actually really interesting
and that got me thinking about um
some you know taking some of the ideas
that he had
in superconductivity
um which is which has a semblance of the
same type of quantum mechanics many body
quantum mechanics in super fluidity like
type like for example superfluid helium
where the helium atoms in a sense coupe
appear right to form to go into the
superfluid state
um
and the idea was um our idea and was
basically to think of
with the the modern version of the idea
which is um work that i did with my
former post like evan mcdonald and david
spurgle was that we said the idea was
that in the early universe you have it's
the thing that's cooper parent performed
like a superfluid
um a dark cork so you have quarks
that are produced um during inflation by
a mechanism that we spelt out um you
know usual particle production mechanism
of cosmic inflation but what happens is
that this is a strongly coupled
phenomenon
um and akin to some some um
you know color superconductivity ideas
that you know krishna rajapal and alfred
and frank wilshek and others developed
that you can basically
um you know it's very preferred very
much preferred the cosmos cosmological
dynamics have very low temperatures
um
instead of these quarks forming a
thermal state they they actually there's
an attractive channel and they cooper
pair up to form a superfluid
and um and so the idea is that the dark
matter in this case is a superfluid made
up of these dark quarks
that that is an opposite different than
the superfluid that we find in
in bosonic particles like an axion like
ultralight axions can also
do a similar thing and they're
distinguishing um observables um for
these two different types of superfluids
yeah but the basic idea is just like you
know think of a superfluid in a bucket
and fill out the universe with this
superfluid and it has
properties very similar to that of a
dark what a dark halo could have
and in a recent paper we actually showed
that um you get very naturally stable
dark halos made up of this superfluid
and it has um certain predictions having
to do with excitations you know like in
a superfluid if you rotate it you can
get um excitations called protons and
vortices yeah well you get these types
of objects um in galaxy in halos you can
have substructure that will look like
line-like defects
and one of the things we're working on
right now
is actually um
is to um you know look at basically what
kind of observables you'll see um
through like things like gravitational
lensing um one final thing there is some
connection to chiral gravitational waves
in this i know that's something that
you've um
as director of the simon's observatory
um you guys are thinking about but we
can talk about that offline yeah yeah
this is it's about your book and your
ideas and one of the ideas you talk a
lot about um is a very provocative idea
i would say and that is you know the
origin of dark energy
might be kind of the waste
by-product of plants
and that's with uh your buddy jaron
lanier the uh the co the inventor of
virtual reality uh brother that you
introduced me to up in northern
california one day and his tree house uh
wandered through there uh love to get
the two of you guys to to chat about
your recent paper together
we'd love to do that yeah lee i had leon
over the summer and he mentioned that
you guys are leading that effort but
anyway you guys had this this
i have to say it is literally far out so
talk about this idea what is the dark
energy i mean first of all
why is this a problem like you know in
in nature we're always trying to like
explain things but as feynman says in
character and physical laws you noted
you know at the end it's like well it
might be that nature has an infinite
layer of onion skins and the pleasure of
finding things out is just peeling away
a couple layers not like getting to the
center of the onion what what do you
have then you don't even have an onion
ring i mean that's like nothing right so
talk about that why why is it like why
do we need to figure out what dark
energy is what's the big deal
that's a very good question
um
so let me say that um what i'm about to
say here is coming from a place of
ignorance ultimately because if we if i
was able to articulate what the problem
really is that i'd probably be close to
solving it right and
you know a big part of this part of
writing this book too is as a practicing
theorist and physicist right and the
only reason i love talking to experiment
bright experimenters like you we're in
the process of trying to understand what
the problem is
because once you understand the problem
like you know more clearly then you
might have a go at tackling it with with
you know or going beyond it and um or to
even realize that there was no problem
to begin with
so
the way i would like my in with dark
energy is to think
often times it's usually formulated as
or the unity except the you know the
universe is excel the expansion rate the
universe is accelerating and you know
that is one aspect to dark energy
because
the way that feeds in
to einstein's theory of general
relativity is that if you have
a form of energy
um that has negative pressure equation
of state um you know and like
a baryotropic equation of state that's
negative
um
then you know you get this repulsive
effect this accelerate expansion
but there's another side the cosmo dark
energy problem and that is
that
what's doing this is uh is something a
form of energy momentum
in or energy let's say
that's feeding into general and into
into space space time
um that source in this and that
that thing actually is indistinguishable
from something called a cosmological
constant or vacuum energy these words
are in this you know interchangeable
and so what does that mean it means
actually we don't have to go all the way
to outer space to talk about dark energy
take a tiny bit of empty space right in
front of you
the same space in front of us
there's the same space way out there and
this
space in front of us
there's energy associated with empty
space so this vacuum energy is actually
if i take a cubic centimeter right there
is a tiny bit of this vacuum energy in
this in this piece of empty space and
people like richard feynman right and
and his predecessors and um
contemporaries taught us
how quantum field theories okay how
interacting quantum fields can generate
particles coming into
a virtual particle an electron positron
pair coming in and then
annihilating very quickly that process
will generate some of this energy in
empty space and we have many of these
processes that we can calculate in our
standard model with the same precision
that we go to calculate the g2 of muon
for example right all these precision
things that we calculate in the standard
model and we go measure the same
precision predicts actually that empty
space should have way too much vacuum
energy than what what is actually
observed so the question is where is it
hiding
what do we need to um
what what do we need to do at um to our
standard model our precision standard
model
to get rid of this vacuum energy so the
idea the part of this cosmological
constant dark energy problem if i can
summarize it is that we know that this
vacuum energy that's making this
universe um accelerate but there's way
too little of it per cubic centimeter
than what we should expect by our very
precision the most precision theories
that we have quantum electrodynamics for
example the standard model
right so the question is what you know
what's going on between how the standard
model
speaks to general relativity that that
that's um
that's causing this huge discrepancy
between what we observe
and what the theory is actually
predicting there should be way too much
vacuum energy and a piece of empty space
in front of our faces where is it and
that's one way of maybe characterizing
the dark energy slash cosmological
constant problem
does that help yeah absolutely now if i
told you stefan that um you know the
cosmological constant uh we just got an
update from past guest on the show adam
reese he said actually no you know what
uh it's more consistent with a
um you know a cosmological concept with
a with a positive equation of state and
um you know it's not really a
cosmological constant at all it's more
like you know matter or radiation
something
um wouldn't you throw out your theory i
mean
the thing i'm getting at is that you
know we talk about uh string theory and
it's been around for a long time and you
and i were there during some of the big
revolutions you talked about in the book
on mel desena you know that was
happening right as we were graduating
around then 2000-ish
and um
ads cft
and i you know lately i've been doing a
lot of videos i'll actually have i had a
video out last week by the time this
comes out um and it was about you know
what is the minimum that string theory
has to do
and contrary distinction to lenny suskin
who is a guest on the show he has these
books the theoretical minimum
um yeah but what's the experimental
minimum in other words if i tell you you
know this only works in in uh you know
in a positive you know anti-disinter
space not the center space like we live
in um it shouldn't you just stop working
right now i mean like why do they keep
going with it you talk a little bit
about you know ads cft why do people
even talk about string theory if it
predicts you know the exact opposite
behavior in a negative cosmological
constant and we know the universe has a
positive you know dark energy if not a
cosmological constant
yeah i mean so
that's right so i think one of the you
know one of the things that theorists do
is that we work with things called toy
models right remember brandenburger we
have a toy model we have a pencil to
talk about something standing on a you
know
an idealized surface and you know it
falls
so we we we tend to have toy mouth so i
would think of like you know these
solutions that are given to us in string
theory where
a negative cosmological constant um is
preferred as solutions of a theory and
so yeah i mean you know by studying
those those solutions those toy models
they hope to gain more insight
into the real the real deal where you
know where we get the positive
cosmological constant and i think that i
like the work that string theorists um
some of them are doing where they
literally break the theory they
literally you know they introduce a
cosmological content in some really
you know not contrived but very elegant
ways and i i'm a big believer in like
it's important to break your theory
meaning that whatever your theory is and
if there are underlying principles that
govern the theory
in this case in string theory there are
certain symmetries that work that you
try to preserve in looking for solutions
and if you break if you break that then
usually you you break some
principles in a theory like oh the bad
one of course is if you break unitarity
of the theory right
um
so anyway the point here is that
or you you reintroduce anomalies into
the theory things like that so but i
think it's useful to
to have toy models and then once you
gain enough experience like actually
jump in it and try to make contact with
the real world
our job i think as theorists
is to
you know it's our tradition has always
been
you know when einstein found and
discovered general relativity you know
the boom the perihelion of mercury and
you know and then you know people are
looking at cosmological solution lamitre
right um found the first i think he was
one of the first to find the to talk
about the conic cup the you know the
the the the day
yesterday whatever the day before there
was
before there was yesterday whatever the
saying was
um you know
um but anyway my point is that there's
always been a tradition where no matter
what kind of theorizing you're doing
behind it there's always a um
a standard and an ethic to try to
connect as best as you can
to observations and especially to those
that cannot be explained by current
theory
yeah and that's certainly true and in
fact in the video that i made i'll link
to it in this video um i say just that i
say it was important and it's fine to be
guided by what einstein did that was a
retrodiction you know he's just
explaining which is huge you know what
that which newton lacked uh but he also
had all these predictions by the way he
thought most of his predictions were
either unobservable in in practice or
you know
were irrelevant from gravitational
lensing to gravitational waves so you
know it's too bad because he could have
had a good career
i want to talk now about uh about robert
brandenburger about mentors because it
seems like you know again yes you're an
outsider but you're an insider i mean
your mentor was one of the most
preeminent theorists in
in our generation right robert
brandenberger sat on my committee found
some errors in the wiring diagram of a
five dimension of a five layer deep
circuit schematic and a high electron
mobility transistor i don't know how he
did that um you know
i'm kidding he did find some errors you
know which which my advisor
exactly yeah i guess i got some some
strings up in there but um but speaking
of strings you give a much better
description than almost any other
description maybe with the exception of
him of string gas cosmology and it's
hard to make me think that i need to
cover this in my in my chapter in my
book because i've been talking about sir
rogers conformal cyclic cosmology we
talked about that talk about paul
steinhardt we talked about the verbiages
in the past you know the steady state
basically but it seems like string gas
cosmology which he did you know kind of
the week before bicep results came out
in 2014 he was like i think the results
are consistent with string gas cosmology
it turned out it was consistent with
dust uh not uh no extreme gas cosmology
or any kind of inflationary cosmology
so dust gas cosmology is the new cause
the ketone the ketone mechanism
i am pretty dirty as a as you know
uh a young dirty you know who um would
say but um but thinking about um these
cosmological models i want to turn now
to cosmology from particle physics uh
that we've been talking about and you uh
are an expert in this and you have many
many ideas about um
about the future and the past and the
universe and i want to ask you know in
that concept in that landscape where
does string gas cosmology fit in because
i don't i don't know that you're still
working on it or even if you ever really
worked on it it seemed like always kind
of like a skunk works project that
robert was working on um talk a little
bit about about this model and what
makes it so appealing to you
and then i'll share some of my feelings
about maybe testing it but what do you
think is so appealing about string gas
cosmology that it warrants a whole
chapter a wonderful chapter in the book
yeah yeah into the cosmic matrix that's
a type of that chapter um
yeah so i did work part of my phd
dissertation was to extend string
because remember
in the early days of string theory the
fundamental degrees of freedom um were
just thought to be fundamental strings
and then well well polcinsky
came out with the d brains and and
and lee as well um they um
realized that there were
non-perturbative degrees of freedom in
the theory which are hyper services that
strings can end on called dericio or
d-brains
and um and so the question is if you
look at this idea of string gas
cosmology um you have to also consider d
brains and let me just say a basic idea
of string gas cosmology
it's very um kind of simple
so in the standard big bang cosmology
before we talk about so there's no
inflation in the standard big bang hot
big bang cosmology of hoyle and others
um which is that the universe is starts
off very much radiation dominated and in
the very end it's hot and dense and then
you extract you extrapolate that back to
early times and then you find you have a
curvature and a density singularity um
at t is equal to zero but then the
solution basically smoothly expands
right um and and cools
so
if you think about the initial state of
the universe is really just a hot dense
gas of radiation
so the idea of string gas is to just
simply replace
um those particle degrees of freedom
which is a hot dense gas of particles
okay and quant you know the particle
excitations of quantum fields
replace the early universe by a hot
dense gas of strings
and when you do string theory now in
that context what you find is that when
you look at the density um
um
and and singularity actually when if you
for example look at the density and the
temperature it no it no longer now goes
to an infinity but it reaches a bounded
value called a hagerdon temperature and
the density goes finite on you so
actually you realize that the
singularities that you would get in a
hot big bang radiation dominated
particle-like scenario
gets replaced now those singularities
get replaced they get regulated now
because the stringing degrees of freedom
basically soak in all of those um you
know it basically well i don't want to
get into the physics of why that's
happening but basically the string
degrees of freedom basically regulate um
that and it has to simply do with the
notion that
strings are extended objects and so if
you try to zoom in there are symmetries
in string theory that basically tell you
that when you zoom in you end up with
it's as if you're moving in a a big
string again so there's this is called
target space duality you know physics
that are very small that becomes physics
that are very big there's a symmetry
there that strings um enjoy that
particles don't so when they're making a
long story short that theory in its
early stages was that basic idea that
you can
him and vaffa you know
came up with this theory said that
there's a sense like um
a universe um a big universe and a small
universe and they're kind of dueled to
each other they they related this in you
know interchangeable when you get to the
big bang singular
now the reason why i revisited this is
that
um
the story gets really interesting
because if you start saying well
what kind of cosmology is this is this a
bounce that you come out of
um so there's some pre-existing large
universe and and i was kind of ex using
string gas cosmology to say that okay
and um if you
one of the things you might want to do
and i think robert and and cameron varfa
did this was to say
let's
try to do build up a cosmology that is
intrinsic to the theory itself
so not let's not try to do inflation
with string theory let's see what string
theory says that's natural to it in
terms of a cosmology and it seems that
this is the more natural thing that if
you start off with a hot stringy early
universe it will naturally want to
you know
do what string gas cosmology says it
does
the other thing that was interesting was
i used that though to motivate
um
the question of
well
um what really does happen
at the earliest time in stringout
cosmology
and this is where i brought in some
ideas that actually
you know
it you know the um bangs fishler suskin
and schenker and bfss
had a way of reformulating string theory
into something that they that edwin
called m theory now m will be matrix
theory that basically you give up
um smooth the description of space-time
so space becomes very discreet
so you give that up you give up the
continuum as a principle
and i i wanted to do this um as a nod to
richard feynman because feynman ends the
character of physical law by saying you
know he talks about these principles you
know symmetry you know energy
symmetry variants and all these
principles
and he says we maybe we have to give up
one of these principles and he did talk
about giving up the continuum but then
he got stuck about
you know if you do this you're screwed
but that's exactly what matrix theory
did it gives up the continuum in this
interesting way so it was a not to find
men
and then to say okay listen if we if we
now say string gas cosmology now goes
into a matrix description
what would that look like and i kind of
end with that question and then
coincidentally robert brandenberger and
his um students put a paper out
literally saying that string gas
cosmology um
is um the before there was that there
was a matrix the universe is basically a
non-community of a discrete space-time
and then the smooth space time emerged
so it's like an emergent cosmology right
which is very interesting right it lends
itself more to ideas of of um condensed
matter physics right where things are no
longer fundamental right but things can
emerge right
from fundamental degrees of freedom one
most appealing thing to me is that it
makes a concrete prediction
in wild contrast to inflation which is
that it predicts a background of
primordial tensor modes but they are
predominating at the smallest scales
rather than the biggest scales
and you know i wonder
because
a theory like inflation like string
theory has a certain as you called it
herd mentality you know it's not for me
to call it that but you're in the field
and and that's you're you're right and
you know i can say i agree with that in
a lot of sense but i'm not prac i'm not
a practicing theorist
uh some of my best friends are theorists
though um
but the point of my curiosity is that
it's falsifiable
in that it could be ruled out and rather
than ruled in and but again you know in
the back of my mind i'm always wondering
you know are we too beholden to karl
popper you know are we as lenny suskin
called him on this on this podcast he
called the you know the paparazzi
it's not like girdle right girdle said
yeah girdle said you know certain things
are are fundamentally not provable
within a formal axiomatic set uh but
popper was just like yeah it's good if
you can falsify things but you know as
as my friend uh steven c meyer pointed
out you know you can
you know astrology astrology makes
falsifiable predictions right you know
i'm going to win the lottery tomorrow or
you know tomorrow i'm going to find you
know uh true love if i'm single yeah
those are falsifiable so now astrology
is science that's ridiculous um and
hearkening back to what i said earlier
about maxwell and you know if twitter
existed back then and you know he tweets
out about the wheels and the vortessies
and
faraday did it and he was right but you
know his successor in some ways maxwell
did and he was wrong so um
i guess the question you know that i
want to kind of wrap things up on is you
know is there
is there room again for
non you know for mainstream outsiders
let me let me just make up a term
oxymoron um you know can you have
something take the
energy the wind that's in the sails of
of string theory
and inflation the two dominant theories
of particle genesis and cosmogenesis
respectively um and talk about you know
can you divert some of that energy
intellectually to other pursuits
and even you know if if if you could how
would that look i mean are you going to
hire somebody you know if a young
stephon alexander came to your
department right now brown universe
one of the top departments in the world
two nobel laureates on the faculty uh
including uh you know and then plus you
and and and jim gates i mean it's just
like so it's it's only grown since i've
left right i think it was correlated by
my leaving uh that you guys grew so much
but
you know if a young stefan alexander
forget about the name forget about all
the cool stuff that you've done
recording jazz albums right you you know
getting a leading harlem gallery of
science
being president nsbp take away all that
take your name off the cv take away all
the you know all the struggles that you
went through
god comes to you gal comes to you he or
she says here's my ideas you know cosmic
vedic energy
alien dark energy
what do you say what would you honestly
do in that situation
good i would i would not crush that
spirit but um
i i'll do what i what i'm doing now um
which is that i um
you know i'll i give them i i give a
project
that really
you know lets them sharpen that
and develop a skills uh a solid skill
set so they um you know so they're
versed in the in the tradition
um
and then um and i create i create a
forum i create an environment
where um my students um and postdocs and
those are like there really is um you
know you are encouraged to just
say just say things and just um
use each other's sound boards um
so it's sort of like right you know you
it's it's not a
and but it also means that if you throw
something at me i'm gonna you know i'm
gonna like
you you should expect in a very playful
way and in a way that is um that's em
embracing
um in jazz music we you know this uh um
albert murray the great theorists
um who mentored with marsalis and you
know the
the brain behind uh jazz at lincoln
center
called it um antagonistic cooperation
you know you go to the cutting session
and it's your turn to solo now but the
rest of the band you know they're going
to throw stuff at you um they're going
to take you on a wild twist and turn but
it's in but it's coming from a place of
because i expect you i expect you to
to generate um great ideas wild ideas
and we're gonna we're gonna take it
seriously but you know
we're gonna tear it up tear it apart
and and i and and they're encouraged to
do the same with me i think really
creating that where people are not um
shamed or stigmatized to say uh to have
ideas or be wrong okay the idea of being
afraid of being wrong no
be wrong it's okay
we can't we can't make progress if
you're not if you're not wrong otherwise
because
staring the wrong thing into something
that's right
right and um
and you know there's other things like
who gets to be wrong who's allowed to be
wrong who is not
right so kind of like democratizing that
um who gets to be right who gets to be
wrong who gets to speculate
um
who gets to theorize
um
you know i'll give you an example peter
warren um wrote a um he you know he has
a great blog i
um
you know and
but anyway just to give you a story
about that like he wrote a paper the
other day
about um
a version of basically gravity week
unification the idea that you know
you're told to not embed an internal
symmetry you'd like the lorentz group
sorry a space-time symmetry
with an internal symmetry like those of
the standard model
but he wrote a beautiful paper the other
day why is that why are you what does
that mean that you're told not to do
that is that just like no not to work
because there's some forbidden you know
yeah there's a no growth theorem by
coleman and weinberg um
the coleman weinberg theory
um i believe this is eric weinberg uh if
i'm
not
um we can fact check that the coleman
weinberg theorem has um certain axioms
um as you know or a loophole and there
are loopholes of course behind this that
says that if you take a space-time
submission like the lorenz group which
is the rotation group plus um you know
boost so so the group so3 comma one
um you can't take a subgroup of that for
example right and identify it with an
internal symmetry like su-2
so so3
is locally isomorphic to su-2 and so you
can imagine thinking oh maybe i can take
this so3 of the lorenz group and figure
out a clever way of saying that that is
the su-2 of the weak well i also played
some of this game as well many years ago
it's like let's break the rules let's
break this no-go theorem and um and see
you know what the loophole is and and so
anyway he recently wrote a paper that
was really
you know also technically very strong
and so you know what i did i mean
i invited him to get a seminar at brown
you know you know a theory seminar yeah
um
because i sort of feel like you know
like we need to we need to hear from him
right
um
and
this idea of like democratizing who gets
to be heard who gets you know to
speculate who gets to break the rules
is um to me
something that i'm having a lot of fun
with these days
yeah right if you look at you know
wolfgang paoli and you say and sorry you
can't speculate you know on the uh
conservation of
energy as sacrosanct and you can't order
another particle uh
you know if you'd said after him
you know i don't know if he would let
you do that but anyway uh the point is
yeah we don't know
where the right answer is going to come
from and
you know i think it's like walking that
dichotomy of being enough of an insider
that you know what happened in the past
so you can respect the great because the
one thing that shines through in this
book is that you are a scholar in other
words you study not only the the subject
matter the equation the history
the uh the milieu the cultural milieu in
which these things were developed um and
that's part of being a master that's
part of being an expert in my opinion at
least
and you embody this trait that i've
spoken about many times in my book even
um the word scientist in russian you
know that i learned from alexander
palmerev your friend
another poet
alexander and alexander those great
papers but uh but the
you know the notion of the word
scientist in russian means someone who
is taught and to me to be to be a good
teacher you had to have been a good
student and to be a good teacher you
also have to teach people in the future
and so you know i really i do you know i
give you incredible accolades and and uh
and really much respect because
you you're not just content at doing the
calculations you're bringing people up
you're inspiring the youth you're the
president of national society black
physicist
leader of the harlem gallery of science
the hip-hop museum let's talk a little
bit about those organizations for a
little bit um why is that important i
mean i i've talked to you about this you
and i are our brothers right i say why
are you continuing to pay the black tax
in other words you are working your ass
off harder than i am i don't have to
like opine on you know how do we how do
we bring up the next generation of
underrepresented uh men and women the
next generation of leaders you know i
don't get asked to do that because i'm
white you know you have to pay this tax
and my and our you know female you know
sisters in in science they have to do it
you know because they're women i don't
want to get too woke about it but but
that's true right i mean you have an
excess burden that i don't have to do
and you go above and beyond it why do
that why i mean don't you want to get to
the heart of the matters in the universe
and get back to your research
yeah so it's a dance and i think um
after my tenure of nsbp
president i will
yeah i have to get back and um um devote
um time because you know time is um
limited time is um
finite
um and so yeah um
you know it's kind of selfish because
actually
um
it
i get really a lot of um i a lot of i
gained a lot of pleasure from watching
and you know
you know my you know especially students
um like yeah one of the things i really
do enjoy still doing is that like you
know with nsbp or the han gallery
science just talking to students and
talking science with them and getting
you know um sort of watching them
develop their superpowers you know like
watching that oh yeah you come back you
learn how to do a jacobian
transformation like and they they get a
kick there's something really cool about
um
engaging in that process the other thing
too is that
they
it's selfish because sometimes i rely on
them to
to throw things at me that i would never
think about because they're coming at
coming up things from a pers you know
from
a beginner's mind perspective right john
coltrane would say he wished he had the
heirs of a baby he wished he didn't know
too much music theory because then he
could listen to music in the purest most
pristine way you know um so like there's
something
so yeah there is a part where i really
do enjoy
get a lot of joy out of that the
in terms of the harlem gallery of
science and the hip-hop museum the
universal hip-hop museum where i will be
leading um
the stem initiatives um in the hip-hop
well you know i was one of those those
kids and you know growing up um
with
when hip-hop music was being developed
in the 80s and the bronx you know doing
that part of the
hip-hop evolution coming in from the 70s
and you know we were
we were behaving like scientists we were
taking a sampler a digital sampler
and you know
modifying it right to sample in ways and
sample things that it was never really
designed to do
you know and grandmaster flash was
basically studying the moment of inertia
like you know of different types of
turntables to um and you know and you
know designing new types of crossfaders
and the electronics with that so
like just the idea that the um
the content and the what's the word like
you know the the experimental tools that
we um
that are the um
the objects okay of scientific inquiry
the palette is much larger than just
like being at a blackboard with chalk or
being in a lab you know with something
with an amplifier it you know it can
look like you know it can look like um
you know electronic music it can look
like you know um breakdance and it can
look like you know the the you know the
the the rhyme patterns of the flow of
you know so i think that you know the
patterns the patterns of different
polyrhythms and what that has to say
about geometry so i think that
we use these the idea that we can use
these um these ways of engaging really
bright and promising young people and
show them that there's science there too
there's amazing physics and chemistry
and biology and electronics and those
things that they're so interested in and
use that as a rabbit hole so that you
know they can express
whatever it is whatever song they're
going to play in their scientific career
i think is what what's actually exciting
about that those engagements
well professor stefan alexander
president of the national society of
black physicist
servant servant humble servant that's
her
humble servant i heard it said by the
past one of the past presidents that
you're
one of the best presidents they've ever
had i'm not going to get into the
details because i don't get you in
trouble but anyway um
one of my favorite hip-hop group was a
group called dead prez
i want to ask you uh one final question
because we played into the impossible in
the past
um uh where i ask you these existential
questions i just want to ask one this
time um you get you get one bite at the
apple this time in uh you and i are both
50 now by the time this comes out
not another one bites the dust
no no we're not going to do that we're
going to talk about my sequel my next
book uh a farewell to arms another one
bites the dust i want to uh ask you 50
years from now 50 10 to the 50th years
from now
what uh what let's just say 50 years
from now
what one
chapter would you most like to have the
answer to
in other words this book is full of
puzzles and mysteries of conundrums of
questions there's nothing um
there's nothing solved in the sense that
like you know you're you're just
describing the double slit experiment
for the fifty thousand times you know no
no that's not what this is about um this
book is about a manifesto a a challenge
to future physicists the same way that
that hawking ends with you know if we
can get you know a theory of everything
we'll know the mind of god i happen to
dispute that but but anyway
of these you know 9 10 11 chapters and
this wonderful book out now from basic
books
shout out to tj kelleher who is uh
uh i've known him for a long time
greatest editor in the history of the
universe of universes
yeah i mean i've had on so many uh basic
book uh authors he owes me uh he owes me
a bottle of
of uh blue bottle coffee or whatever you
guys drink over there on the east coast
um i want to ask you of all the chapters
in this book
what would you most be curious about
come on you can you know it's like my
mom you met my mom and i'd always ask
her mom you know who's your favorite kid
i've got three brothers and she'd say oh
that's like asking me to choose my left
hand or my right hand i said mom you're
left-handed come on of course you're
gonna choose your left hand of course
i'm your favorite no no but um but i
wanna ask you there's gotta be one thing
in here that you know that's that's
equal but above equal
what question do you most wanna know the
answer to if you'll permit me
yeah so you know it's funny you say that
i'm looking at a chapter and this
chapter was related to actually a crazy
woo book i was reading as a grad student
um about and it was a book called zen
mine begin his mind by by um suzuki yeah
so our chapter called
the zen of quantum fields and maybe can
i read uh just one section of this yeah
yeah of course let's go
so um
and let me see if i can if i could yeah
so because um
um
my first introduction to eastern
philosophy was a book entitled zen mind
beginner's mind by zen master
shan ryu suzuki
um
and suzuki had a more had a most
interesting metaphor for existence
imagine a stream flown towards a
waterfall when the water leaves a cliff
a droplet of water leaves the stream and
at some point rejoins the stream
life is like that droplet of water and
the stream is like the universe
during the time between when we are born
quote unquote and when we pass away
quote unquote we are like the water
droplet feeling like we are separate
from the universe as a whole
but before we are born and after we die
we are part of the stream the universe
i remember one wanted there to be some
truth on
to suzuki's metaphor
so in what way
um
what way could we be connected to the
universe in the poetic manner described
by suzuki
and so
i use that metaphor
and i end this chapter before i go into
talking about quantum field and why
quantum field theory is kind of saying
something like this right again
metaphorically and i say
i end with the last paragraph of that
chapter after going through quantum
field theory in that sense and i say
consider electrons in a star millions of
light years away from earth
while there are many electron particles
there's only one electron field
that they are born from
those electrons and the electrons that
are in you and me were created as
quantum excitations from the same
universal electron field in the early
universe
in fact every other particle including
quarks and neutrinos in the universe
quanta that emerge from their
corresponding real vibrations
it's in this suzuki sense that we are
tethered to the fundamental fabric of
the universe anyway so again it's uh
it's a it's as you said it's a one of
these uh
dream ideas and but i you know all we
actually connected to the universe in
this poetic manner right
uh and and you know it seems that the
lessons that we're learning of his
oneness and this wholeness
um
is not just maybe
but actually closer to the to the
picture of say quantum field theory and
you know the early universe that we're
trying to discover trying to learn and
you are trying to experimentally uh you
know probe
how's that yeah that's great that is
great well stefan
my oldest deer dearest friends i'm one
of them
top two or three that i've known longer
than anybody even then my wife
uh i want to thank you for this book
because it is a gift
it's uh it's mesmerizing it's
inspiring it's thoughtful it's soulful
and uh of course it has uh
it has a hell of a beat and has a hell
of a rhyme to it and uh i just want to
thank you for uh for kind of rekindling
this love to me of of the big question
that's why i got into being a physicist
i may be a different reflection of it
in that i'm an experimentalist but you
know and i going back to 1993
we first met each other
uh you know i just can't believe that
you have uh that you remember these
things that we've gone through and that
have really
steeped in you this unique approach to
science i want to thank you and i want
you to give my regards to professor
griff um flavor flav
no
chuck d i'd love to meet that man and
you know maybe maybe we could all do
something with chuck maybe we can do
something with chuck in the future that
would be fun i'd love to get him on the
podcast with you and i said one last
score yeah go for it
i also you know um you know again this
book the thing about fear of black
universe it was like a you know think
about quantum superposition it had many
different superposition different types
of meanings
one of it actually was my fear my fear
of kind of coming out
clean and say looking i i you know i got
into physics because i had these bigger
questions about my existence
and i think you know
some of it is your fault because when
you wrote your book you all i think you
writing your book and you kind of coming
out and talking about god and talking
about
um
these matters okay on
um
as well as your physics and so in in in
connection to your physics i also i
think it was a thing it gave me the hall
pass to write my book so i want to thank
you
all right
i will take your
your incomia your blurb which you were
kind enough to put on the last book that
i wrote and uh you feature also in my
upcoming book as well but we'll save
that for another another time professor
stefan alexander
uh
professor brown university theoretical
physics cosmologist saxophone if you
want to take us out with a little riff
or are you the reason
i don't know what the read fell out of
my office no no no no all right all
right i'll put in some public enemy i'll
try
i'll try and get some rights free you
know uh fight for your right to party a
party for your right to fight
um i want to thank you stefan for
sharing your time on socks yeah
okay
all right my friend thank you so much
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you
[Music]